on the next episode of StarTalk it's a
cosmic queries featuring The expertise
of a colleague of mine from Princeton
University the name is Gaspar bakus and
he is at the department of astrophysics
there where he has developed a system of
small telescopes to discover exoplanets
so we're going to find out how does that
work why does a small telescope still
get to contribute to a field that's on
the frontier and we also learn how these
satellite trails that we've read all
about and seen videos of launched from
rockets and how they affect the data
that he's searching for as well as the
beauty and Majesty of the night sky that
we've all missed ever since cities have
become electrified
all coming up on Starcon
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
this is yet another Cosmic queries
Edition this one we solicited questions
from our patreon members on topics such
as the search for exoplanets the
telescopes that discover them but also
what is happening to our night sky and
the new kind of light pollution
satellites trailing across the heavens I
got with me Matt Kirsch and Matt my
co-host how you doing man I'm I'm very
good I'm excited about this topic not
least because
um a couple of weeks ago as a birthday
present from my wife I went to Mount
Wilson Observatory for a a lecture and
then a look through the big telescope
very good very good yeah so so I I'm I
feel like I'm I'm up at an amateur level
now on this but I want to hear from the
pros excellent excellent so what there
are people who are experts in all of the
things I listed one of whom is actually
just across the river across the moat
here we call it the Hudson River over in
New Jersey uh is a colleague of mine
from Princeton Department of
astrophysical Sciences Gaspar bakos bar
welcome to StarTalk yes hi everyone I'm
glad to be here excellent excellent and
you are a pi on a project called hat net
which is search for exoplanets uh and of
course people I don't think everyone
thinks much about the fact that in any
given spot on earth uh where most people
live you don't see the whole sky so if
you're going to find exoplanets in a
place you're not looking what do you do
yeah um yeah so um
indeed there is a project called Head
net which is uh which is an automated
telescope system uh because finding
exoplanets with the naked eye would be
really very challenging I would say
impossible
um but um the idea behind behind robotic
telescopes is they can actually scan uh
monitor big areas of the sky Non-Stop
and then we can use computers to analyze
all the data and we can place these
robotic telescopes to like uh fancy
astronomical locations which have clear
skies high mountains and have internet
and power that's getting very difficult
and they're not very large so it's not a
big disruption to the physical location
oh yeah correct direction in design and
this is a this was an amazing thing that
um we realized about sort of 20 years
ago that that we can actually do Cutting
Edge science with tiny telescopes um
because Stars when the planet goes in
front of them they blink and that blink
can be detected with a small telescope
if it's all carefully engineered and run
so
apparently it's not you have telescopes
in multiple places on Earth and why why
did you do that
oh yeah so um the the transits are
Elusive and and the transit of a planet
that the time instance when it goes in
front of its star
um will have nothing to do whether it's
daytime or night time on Earth from a
given location so it might actually go
in front of its star and the star blinks
when it's brought daylight here in
Princeton
um so the idea is to put telescopes
around the globe uh at Tactical
longitudes so we can observe Around the
Clock in other words the Sun never rises
above our telescope Empire
it never it never sets it's an
equivalent that this whole British
Empire
it never Rises either but logically it
also never Rises but okay so so you can
cover it so you've got I love your
phrase tactical longitudes uh but now
what about latitude
um yeah you can also be tactical with
latitudes because here's the thing if
you go too far to the South you freeze
to death and I don't like that if you go
too close to the equator then you have
too much humidity and jungles which are
lovely things but it's just not good for
Australia too far south if you're in the
southern hemisphere if you're in the
southern in the north it's the same
thing I mean and plus in the north if
you go too far north there's no ground
you can yes you can attach to it there's
another problem so most people don't
know that Santa Claus lives on an ice
flow okay yeah exactly most
illustrations of Santa Claus at his his
Workshop they have mountains and tree
you know pine trees and things it's like
no no so that's worrying with with
climate change he could like it could
disappear he could end up yeah this
would be Santa Claus in a bathing suit
right just sitting there on the floor
well it's already happening last year
the the Arctic did not freeze over it
was in the news Okay ships can be
Crossing it at any time or something so
it's like so where are your where your
Southern hemis your telescopes where are
they
um so the first station we built is in
Chile at Las campanas observatory in the
in the Andes so it's a pre-existing
Observatory location right so you didn't
have to build roads you didn't have to
put in the internet like you said you
just ride the pre-existing
infrastructure yeah exactly but we did
pour the concrete Bears we pulled in a
container like a shed for uh instruments
and we hold in all the things and build
all the infrastructure up for our local
installation but there is other
infrastructure already there um the
second one is in Namibia in the Kalahari
Desert there is an existing installation
there called the Hess has telescopes
um so again we had internet we had power
um sort of you know there was
it was uh a bit uh tough in the
beginning
um but it's an amazing place
um and the third one is in Australia and
Outback it's citing spring Observatory
which again has sort of very good
infrastructure all right well very cool
and the last I checked the the catalog
of exoplanets was nicely Rising through
five thousand and uh you're gonna make
predictions about how soon we'll hit
maybe 10 000 doubling that number
yeah that's a that's a that's a very
hard thing to extrapolate let me ask a
different question at what rate are you
discovering exoplanets yeah are you good
at this
well so our rage we actually found 140
something exoplanets between 2006 and
now and our rate has been going down
because uh space missions have been
contributing majority of the discoveries
um but you know space missions have a
limited lifetime so Kepler was a famous
one that flew from 2009 through sort of
um and then Tess is now highly
productive Mission which will run for a
limited time and test is itself a an
acronym was it Transit transiting
exoplanet surveys satellite there you go
yeah yeah right right so so I'm
fascinated by this so so but you'll
continue cranking with or without the
space observatories is what you're
saying well an idea what we do is we
complement the the data coming from
space let's say tests observes an area
for 27 days uh Non-Stop and it finds
transiting planets now some of the
transits will be single Transit there
will be just a blip in the light curve
and we don't know what's when the next
is happening we don't know and but if we
complement it with ground-based data we
can solve for the period and then so
test makes the discovery now you follow
up to verify that it's that it's a
repeating phenomenon because they just
see one blip that could have been
anything oh yeah yeah and there's many
false positives that's other thing that
this 5000 Planet candidates right now
but I think the number of confirmed
planets with masses measured say is
about 270 from tests so there's like a
huge difference between uh between the
two all right so it's still a lot of
work to to happen there so now you're
also involved
and you're a part of a documentary
called Dark sacred night that's that's
some powerful words there so what's
going on with that
well I've been uh I I grew up on the
Dark Skies as a kid I was at the Moon
where would you where did you have dark
skies
kid he was yeah yeah you were on an
astronaut okay yeah fess up to us where
where were you when you grew up well I I
grew up in the north east part of
Nigeria on the border of Cameroon oh my
gosh I went on a farm and that was there
it is there it is yeah yeah that was
there was no electricity and uh no TV no
no internet no phone but but we had the
dark the dark sky and it was really
amazing um I remember as a five-year-old
looking up and I would see the Milky Way
going down to the fence or whatever the
Horizon you know and um and then I
realized when we moved back to Europe
that this is this is not something I see
from there um at all yeah it's not even
I didn't even know it's there yeah yeah
I mean it's just on the dude like all
that beauty is sort of uh Missing for I
fed pity for for all of us here we just
don't see this thing and I fed uh is it
actually a necessity or is it a
stupidity and after a while I realized
it is more of a stupidity
um if lights were properly designed the
name down it was not wasted then we
would actually see the Milky Way from
majority of the year they have both
civilization plus a dark night skies so
not having our cities any less than it
but just having smarter lighting that is
less wasteful less less pointing up and
escaping less you know what I tell
people when I'm in an airplane and we're
about to do our final Loop to the
airport around the city I'd say to the
person next to me you see that that area
of street lights down there and they say
yeah and they say someone is paying
money they said photons to me in an
airplane
it is doing no good for whatever their
purpose is down on on the estimate now
is
um something like 50 percent of the
light emitted in the US by light
fixtures goes up straight in the sky and
that's pure geometry I'm not shielded
it's like not not rocket science it's
like the simplest thing and the amount
of money which just referred to as right
now the estimate is about three billion
dollars per year is converted into
photons
simply because of the poor design
an airplane
on the show but it because I grew up on
the outskirts to London and then now I
live in Los Angeles and nearly Uber up
in New York and it's just I I remember
the first time I was somewhere that was
sort of remote and in the middle of
nowhere and you could really see the sky
and I was like oh that's what stars are
that's what people used to write poems
about and drop yeah so Matt that moment
for me was in the Hayden planetarium oh
is that what this guy looks like oh
really so Matt you uh this is a hybrid
nice conversation with our guests but
also we solicited questions from our
audience so uh Matt what questions do
you have for we absolutely man here
yeah so a bunch a load of patreon
patrons came through with some great
questions so Shane McDaniel says when
you use long exposure detectors how do
you keep them in the same line of sight
through the exposure so all the data
lines up given the Earth is rotating no
space have their own velocity
um I don't know if this refers to a
space mission or or a ground-based
telescope but whatever it is we have
developed tracking on the skies has been
on Earth we have what we call the polar
axis of all side telescopes who sit on
big axis pointed at the rough of the
North Pole which is Polaris at our time
and the telescope spins around this with
what we call cedarial raids and they
also have other fine things like the
auto guide we have a special detector
which is sensing Starlight and would
like nudge the motors left and right to
keep things exactly in the center and
for a space mission it's um similar
techniques they have gyroscopes they can
Orient and plus in space it's somewhat
easier actually to to track because you
know you have less external forces
you're not necessarily like spinning
with the Earth itself so you're pointing
at some Direction
emphasis there you mentioned uh sidereal
time because I don't know the people
know that the Stars revolve around the
earth if I may speak in that way
pre-copernican they revolve it at a
different rate than the sun does
so the sidereal rate is the star rate
that the Suns go around the stars go
around the earth and that's every 23
hours and 56 minutes yes stars make one
complete Loop whereas the sun makes one
complete Loop in 24 hours so yeah so we
got smart people figuring all that out
but you know what what my iPhone does
today is if I want to take a long
exposure it doesn't it doesn't say hold
it really steady well I can do this no
it takes multiple exposures multiple
short exposures and then in software
when the exposure is done it registers
the light in that image Stacks them adds
them and that's my final photo and I
don't even see the the intermediate
stages of it so gasbar what you're
saying is we know enough about the
rotation of the earth to compensate for
it
when we're taking long exposure photos
yeah yeah they have measured the spin of
the earth very well so well that we
actually even see that's not something
we correct for during the night but
sticky speaking we see when the earth
spins down or spins up due to changing
seasons
this is totally bad we we are so good at
knowing the rotation of the earth we can
say when it's varying that's just that's
that's
that's that you're showing off now
the Earth used to be our primary clock
right Earth
and you wouldn't know if the clock was
varying if your clock itself was the
foundation of your time keeping so now
you have to be able to keep time better
than Earth does to then show that Earth
is either speeding up or slowing down uh
yeah exactly right crazy crazy
so Matt what do you have for our guest
well I I'm gonna combine a couple of
questions because I'd love to do that so
there's a question from Mark Bode
firstly from Boulder Colorado who says
the question about the proliferation of
low earth orbit satellites since it
doesn't seem like the rate humanity is
launching these things will reduce
anytime soon what is the best way we can
ensure the skies remain clear and free
of light pollution to enable important
activities such as the search for
extrasolar planets and then also Kevin
Browning from White Deer Texas says how
does low off low orbiting satellites and
space debris interfere with the search
for exoplanets what can ordinary people
like myself who care about the night sky
do to convince Congress or companies
like SpaceX to reduce light pollution
and the number of orbiting satellites
okay so so that's why you have to answer
that in three sentences
actually first why don't you distinguish
for us the difference between light
pollution and satellite pollution
because it's not the same thing is it
yeah
um there are some subtle base here I
would say light pollution has a
ground-based component which is bright
City Lights poorly designed lights going
up in the sky and and Illuminating our
atmosphere and the night sky making it
brighter and the second component which
is fairly new and unexpected so to say
is light pollution coming from
um thousands or soon maybe tens of
thousands of artificial satellites
orbiting the Earth reflecting backlights
from the Sun or emitting radio waves
which is also electromagnetic radiation
so performance light yes so these are
these are the two components um the to
deal with the first one I would say
technically it's sort of a trivial thing
and yet you're not doing it and there
are many other things in the history of
humanity which were trivial and we have
not been dealing with it this is another
example of that um okay but you know to
give some hope I think some of them were
dealt with so we use to pollute the
rivers far more than we do now we used
to pollute our atmosphere with Freon and
with other pollutants that would
decrease Smoke Stacks would yeah I grew
up I have to brush Ash off my shoulders
because every apartment building burned
its own trash and at certain times of
day so yeah when I grew up the sky was
was bad for multiple reasons yeah so you
know London used to be covered in suit
for centuries and now it's sort of clean
compared to that but it used to stink
yeah light pollution which is basically
shielding all the lights aiming them
down where they are supposed to be
lighting and dimming them to proper
levels and not over lighting this is it
and it has not been achieved it's just
stunningly bad
um and I'm clearly amazed that this is
still going on under you know there's
definitely a trend and and a recognition
of going green and being less pollutant
and yet we're wasting like three billion
dollars a year on lighting up the sky
which is very harmful for us it's not
about the Stars by the way you know it's
this thing of yes we want to see the
stars but it's about our own health
which has been now clearly detected to
be very very bad for our heads having
strong ambient nighttime lighting it's
very bad for for nature for ecosystems
and even better actually for safety but
that's a different topic as for the
night uh going back to the question uh
the satellites
um up in the sky
um that's that's a hard problem to solve
um the problem is that sound reflects
back from these satellites and they're
sort of useful in broadcasting internet
now almost everyone in the US has
relatively broadband internet
um if you think like 10 million people
in New York no one complains about
having no internet so that's providing
them with another internet is really
about business and it's not about like
saving the world
um there are some parts of the of of the
Earth where internet is very poor
um say in the middle of the ocean the
middle of the desert there are very few
people there and historically these
people have been if needed have been
using satellite phones for emergency
communications
um there have been some efforts in
dimming the satellites painting them
black they overheated putting them a sun
visor which reflects light in a
different direction I think one idea is
to have a smart design of satellites
being very very conscious about the
light reflected bag
and to have strong limits on the number
of satellites through agencies and and
regulations and by essentially updating
the International Space treaty which is
so outdated that majority of it is from
the 1960s and 70s
completely unprepared for an death
individual launching his own satellites
in numbers of thousands you know there's
nothing in a State Street delighted so
it is a crazy situation that there is
some treaty that is have general
policies about what we can use
satellites for you know no Warfare you
can't you know things like that
um
that there was some ideas about like you
know the Soviet Union was concerned
about America broadcasting TV over the
Soviet Union in the 1970s that was
basically the last major update of the
space treaty
um I think there is a risk of a runaway
process that that companies will start
competing
for the number of satellites and trying
to get
even broader bandwidth and shorter
response time and so it might it might
grow into the tens and hundreds of
thousands if not limited by some Central
agencies so that peace treaty came from
out of the United Nations it has a much
longer title if I remember something
like a treaty for the peaceful use of
outer space it's got some long title
which is very hopeful at the time but I
I agree it's it's now you know 50 years
out of date practically and yeah it's uh
it's got it needs to be modernized and
and many countries signed it right so it
was a it was it had good intent at the
time for sure yeah yeah there's no real
agents at the moment who would say
um you know there's there's agencies who
who who let these tens of thousands of
satellites to be launched and the
decision is essentially based on radio
waves and orbital elements but there is
no environmental element in the
consideration saying no guys you can't
do this you can't paint the Hudson River
red uh it's not yours and anything in
the sky so yours yeah so our crack team
of researchers dug up the full title of
the treaty I've got here I'll read the
treaty on principles governing the
activities of states in the exploration
and use of outer space including the
moon and other celestial bodies see they
needed astronomers in there to make a
good acronym right yeah
do you guys call it the to put
it
there's definitely some really dodgy
space acronyms as well where they've
just taken letters from the middle of
the word as well like you can't do that
it's not allowed not allowed all right
all right really good answer there that
gives us a much deeper insight into
what's going on and what the challenges
are and how hard the solution might be
but that's where you said it's really
just human stupidity for half of the
problem but let me add so let me get
back to one of the specific points of
the question satellites trailing across
the sky does that affect your data
taking when you're trying to discover an
exoplanet big time it does I actually
see the trend in my own data now
um essentially every image I take
during the night I would say up to three
hours after Sunset and from three hours
before Sunrise every image I take
anywhere in the sky will have at least
one Trail or more and those Trails cross
stars and so the light of that star when
I measure will have a big bump in it or
some noise
so it becomes like an intense noise
filtering now some people say oh if you
add co-ed all these images in a smart
way then the satellite trays will
disappear yeah but I don't co-ed them
I'm trying to measure individual images
and all the brightness of all the stars
so it's a it's a co-ed that's that's
lingo for we assume every picture you're
taking
is of the same thing so now you take
them and find out one of them has this
weird streak it's clearly
yeah you drop that out and then
everything else is fine but if one of
the pictures contains something you need
and that's the one that gets dropped out
you lose your data
exactly exactly thinking one of the
things you're looking for is
specifically a change in the image when
something when a planet crosses the star
yes precisely
I mean last time I was I was in Chile a
couple of months ago I let my camera
like my astrophotography equipment out
to take a time lapse and what I saw on
this video in the morning uh when I
reviewed it was I showed they saw this
bright shooting star that's being
crossed by another shooting star and I
said this is remarkable I have this
photograph of two shooting stars
Crossing and then came another like 500
on the horizon this is a regular DSLR
you know end user camera on a tripod and
literally there was like a shower of
satellites on the horizon from Chile and
I'm not hundreds but more it looked
scary these are these are the Alien
Invasion that he's not telling us about
it won't like that it looked like that
yeah it looked like the aliens we did
see when we were up at Mel Wilson There
was um I guess is it starlink is it that
the most satellites but there were
there was a sudden trail of about 10
maybe more satellites in a row just
crossing the sky in a straight line and
it did look it looked very Alien
Invasion like to me it was just I've
never seen no there are a series of a
series of things moving in a direct
straight line
and it's also a cultural thing there are
simulations showing how it will look
like if it does proceed as it is now
essentially it will be very hard to
point out for example for a child there
is a big dipper a little bit all these
moving bright dots in between that thing
when you see that the thing that's not
moving image it will be actually so
confusing it's so we need a video game
shooting down the satellites
one thing I forgot to mention forgive me
um so Matt you went to Mount Wilson
Observatory which was the observatory
that Edwin Hubble used Edwin the pub of
the man not the telescope used to
discover that our Milky Way is not alone
among galaxies in the universe and to
discover that the universe is expanding
and so did they finally get that as a
landmark I think they wanted because
it's a landmark in our understanding of
our place in the universe I don't know
what what's his official designation is
but they're certainly they make a big
deal of that and they're very proud of
that yeah of course to look through the
same
the same telescope that Hubble looked
through it was exactly very it was
pretty impressive too oh this is this is
where as they put it uh in the talk like
that they discovered the universe
essentially here
that's correct that's correct well give
me some more questions see we get one in
before the break absolutely so um
Augustine from Puerto Rico who is the
host of the Curious curiosity dads
scientifica podcast on which I believe
Neil has guested talking about the
Arecibo Observatory I I have and and try
to improve your Spanish the next time
you read that okay yeah that was uh I I
took a I took a very quick run at that
that was serious Gringo Spanish that was
great that was poor and I was hoping it
would be missed but it was not Neil did
not he didn't let that one slide but
Augustine asks can an exoplanet have
life like us on a binary star or red
dwarf oh I love that I love that okay
guess what are you thinking about life
on the planet you're you're looking for
yeah oh yeah yeah I think it's a
fascinating topic
um and um I think the first uh sort of
written record of someone contemplating
about it is is from Asian Greece but
there's also High hands in the 18th
century
pondering about all the stars being Suns
and why not they having their planets
and why some planets actually are like
the Earth and he actually writes in his
there's a very Cosmo theorist where he's
like and there must be all these alien
civilizations on these planets and some
of them might be intelligent and looking
back at us so it was really ahead of his
time
Christian Higgins yeah yeah yes exactly
exactly I think he published his book
sort of to say posthumus just to make
sure he's not burned some snake or
something
um but speculating about life in the
universe yeah yeah if if the universe is
divine because God created it and we are
the Divine creation of God you would not
expect to find life anywhere else but
Earth yeah this is quite heretical yeah
now we know that there are I would the
estimates vary over time because we're
refining it but this basically about 20
percent of solar type stars have a
planet that's Rocky so it's not like a
helium or a hydrogen giant it's Rocky
light Earth and is in what we call the
habitable zone so if you multiply the
400 billion stars in our galaxy take
this about 40 billion of them similar to
the Sun and you multiply that by 0.2
that's about 8 billion
Rocky habitable planets just in our own
Galaxy
the math you're doing in on the Fly
there is you're multiplying big numbers
by fractions right normally when we
think of multiplying numbers we make
them bigger so I just want to clarify
you're you're taking the fraction of the
400 billion at a fraction of what
remained and then you as you hack away
at the large numbers you get the numbers
that have all the features that you're
looking for yeah massive number I think
it's an interesting thing if you look up
at the Milky Way which is lost for 99 of
Americans but if you actually happen to
go to one of the national parks or
travel far you look up at the Milky Way
what's the probability of someone
looking back at you
I think that's a fun question which we
don't know the answer to yet that's a
little creepy though but
the gospel we left out a part of that
question which was what percent might be
orbiting a binary star oh I see yes that
was indeed
um part of the question so
um first of all just to give a tiny
introduction we actually did not know
that there are stable planets around
binary Stars so meaning there's a two
stars orbiting each other very close in
and there's a planet far out orbiting
this binary star it was only in Star
Wars Tatooine is the only one but then
yeah yeah Capital Space Telescope
discovered 16 of them or something like
that so now we know they exist and we
also know that some might be in what we
call the habitable zone so the
probability is is also exists but these
planets are much less frequent than the
ones we that around normal Stars so
right so I guess the point there that
you imply is that if that planet were
orbiting closer to the binary star the
orbit would become less stable because
we get really close to one star and then
far from above but if far enough away it
just sees kind of one average gravity
field is that a fair way to describe it
that's a fair way of describing it and
if it's very far away it fears one
gravity field but it does not feel heat
anymore so yeah okay
you want to be in in the right place
um so for a binary star that's somewhat
more limited and I don't have an an
exact number I don't think anyone does
but we are closing in on that number by
first of all knowing the frequency of
planets around binary stars or getting a
handle on it and and in the future I
think we will soon learn about what
fraction of them are in this habitable
zone and I'll just add that most of the
Stars you see in the night sky are
multiple Planet double in multiple
Planet systems so so it's not a question
about a rare possibility right it's it's
um binary star systems are not rare in
the night sky so it's a very natural
question to wonder whether they could
also be repositories of uh yeah but 70
of stars are
and I have to add that there's another
solution where the two stars are very
far from each other orbiting in say
thousands of years or tens of thousands
of years and both of them host planets
very close in
the opposite of the other one right the
planet orbiting far from the pair and a
pair is or orbiting far from each other
so they carry their own solar systems
around themselves yeah yeah exactly
all right Matt what more questions you
have for our guest yeah we've got some
great questions well one of the one that
I had loaded up from Christopher Stowe
was has just been answered by you it was
about planets and stable orbits around
binary systems so you've covered that
it's just to be clear when we talk about
stable planets it has nothing to do with
their emotional state just to be clear
no planets are notoriously unstable in
many ways
orbitaly stable yes okay there are ways
erupting but just no clear an unstable
planet can either fall into the host
star or get kicked out so that the orbit
does not maintain itself around the
hosts yeah those are the two solutions
and curiously we see the effect of both
um the planets that fell in the star
they pollute the star so you can detect
elements due to
planets in the atmosphere of stars and
the balances were kicked out that's
really amazing I think but they were
detected through what we call Micro
lensing they are dark we don't see them
but they go in front of roughly in front
of a star and they lands the light of
the star due to their gravity and then
you see the background start brightening
up
and with this thing over a decade or two
they actually measured that there are
roughly about 40 billion free floating
planets in our galaxy like one tenth the
number of the Stars a vagabond planets
yeah they have no stars so if you know
you're a some weird civilization that
somehow developed on such a planet
because they have say radioactive heat
coming from the planet they would
actually have a very different view of
the universe like they don't have a
central Star right well at one point
might discover there are even planets
orbiting Stars
the ancient Catholic Church was right
[Laughter]
um well that that does segue quite
neatly I think into a question from
Scott bringlo from Canada Captain Scott
here says with transits being the
predominant method of exoplanet
Discovery what characteristics of the
exoplanet are you not able to identify
using this method and more importantly
what can you identify using this method
I find it fascinating you can glean so
much info from what amounts to a very
small dip immeasurable light from like
this away yeah I guess we would compare
this method to maybe direct direct
Imaging for example let's compare those
two together
yeah okay so
um I'm I'm fascinated by how much we can
actually learn from a transiting
exoplanet and I think that's generally
something is amazing about astrophysics
that we have a lab which is infinitely
far away compared to what we can reach
and yet we can figure things out so the
transit is I think the best example that
you first of all from the Dip the depth
of the transit you can tell how big the
planet is that's pretty obvious like if
it's very deep then the planet is Big
compared to the star and if it's
shallowed and it's tiny because it's
just blotting out light and just blots
out more light yeah yeah that's that's
simple but um you can also measure the
period you see how frequently you see
this transits in front of the star and
you can tell the orbital period of the
planet so these are easy okay provided
you kept monitoring it so it's not just
snapshots you have to keep checking to
wait for that to happen again right so
that's entirely true yeah that's entire
two unique so there could be some
transits where the or orbit is like on a
20-year period or something let's say
and we haven't seen it come back again
right so you've got to be some of those
too yeah then there are some of those
and there are some where you have a
Transit and you miss the second one
because it was daytime or whatever
happened your spacecraft was oriented in
a different direction so it's all of
these but you measure the depth you
measure the period now the other things
that are sort of less trivial but you
can also tell
um
how far the transit is off from the
center line of the star does the planet
go exactly along the line of side
crossing the star along its diameter or
it's like slightly offset or maybe it's
even grazing so you can tell this from
the shape of the transit I think that's
sort of a an interesting thing you can
also tell how to shake by the shape you
mean as the light begins to dim it will
dim at a certain rate yeah and the rate
at which that light dims tells you
whether it crosses the middle or above
or below the equator interesting yeah I
mean even if it's a grazing Transit the
planet just barely goes in front of the
limb of the star you will see this very
shallow very
gradually fainting barely fainting star
whereas if it goes close to the equator
of the star you would see a sharp
decrease in the bra in the brightness of
the star and and the brightness will
stay low until it's worked its way out
again right yeah I'm grazing it'll just
dip in and come back out so so it's
amazing what you can deduce from the
just the shape of that that's
fascinating yeah and now comes the the
so these are the what we call like
geometric parameters which you can
figure out it's not very complicated but
I think what's what's amazing is for
example you can tell
um
what's the angle bear with me between
the planet's orbit
and the spin of the star so is it like a
star spinning say the axis of the spin
points exactly up in some coordinate
system and is the planet orbiting
exactly perpendicular to that or is it
somehow misaligned you can tell this
from combined observations of the light
of this of the transit and doing what we
call radial velocities like measuring
the the red and blue shift of the star
during the transit
um I mean that's amazing thing because
in our own solar system
um we are the sun is about seven degrees
misaligned with respect to the Earth or
the orbital plane of the of the planets
but yeah yeah we discovered planets
which orbit flows in like they orbit
around their stars in two days
and the star is spinning exactly the
opposite direction as the planet's orbit
so it's like upside down spinning and
the planet is orbiting in the same
direction as you would expect
and what yes I mean you can
here's an interesting quiz if the planet
is going in front of the star and then
during that Transit there's actually a
spot on the star
then for a short time instance the
planet will not be covering the star's
bright surface But the spot so you will
see a brightening in middle of the
transit one you can actually you can
actually scan the spots on the star
using the planet going in front which
has been done and Matt the artificial
term for spots on stars are called star
spots
and that stands though
temporary
yeah because sunspots and we didn't know
what they were until long after they
were named but the name stuck and
they're dimmer than the surrounding
brightness of the star so that's so you
so your planet crosses the star and
Crosses a spot
and so because the spot plus the planet
had a certain uh brightness dimming and
then the planet covers the spot
and so now I mean and then the star
brightens up a little bit because now
the spot is not adding to the planet
blockage fascinating yeah yeah and I
left out the most maybe most important
one
um which is
measuring the atmosphere of the planet
and the elements or molecules in the
atmosphere so what you can do is
you take a spectrum of the star when the
planet is not in front of it so you take
a spectrum you see the Starlight split
into wavelength and from it's a very
complicated spectrum and from that you
can figure out what elements there are
in the spectrum of that star and then
you take another one when the planet is
blocking the star and the Starlight is
actually shining through the atmosphere
of the planet and the planet's
atmosphere will be absorbing some of the
Starlight if you compare the two
the spectrum of the star without the
planet in front with the planet in front
you can tell what the atmosphere of the
planet is made of wow
um and I think that's you know you can
tell okay there is an atmosphere here
which has water molecules in it or it
has sodium in it this has been or if it
has oxygen that'd be kind of interesting
because oxygen is not stable and so
something would be making that oxygen
and then these are this would be your
first indication release your first hint
of life I guess yeah so that's why I
mentioned it because exactly the the
best bet right now for what we call a
biomarker is Ozone and oxygen because if
there's no life replenishing these they
would basically oxidize the planets
right Planet would become big red and
rustic instead of what it is
um yeah and in this case in Earth's case
it's the plant life that's making the
oxygen uh not humans or any other animal
life plus you know in the first two
billion years we were not producing
oxygen we were producing methane so this
is not saying that if you see a planet
with no oxygen it has no life if you
can't say that yet right exactly there's
one of one of our best if it does have
oxygen that's a good bet
yeah yeah yeah so um I think the
question also is what we cannot discover
from this
um and
um I mean the transit is such that
obviously what's on the on the dark side
of the planet facing towards us
um we don't see any details we can't
resolve the planet at a Transit will not
resolve spatial features on this planet
there you go um where's the direct
Imaging of one the hope is one day we'll
have enough resolution to actually see
oceans or clouds or something on it yeah
okay yeah yeah so the direct Imaging is
where you can actually see the planet
directly
um that's a separate cottage industry
that's on that's unfolding right now in
our field yeah yeah Matt give me some
more see if we can figure out I'm gonna
combine two again two good questions
you're such a good binder this is also
you know uh our expert here combines
images from small telescopes and that's
what this these questions are about
after David Lee's from uh from Chiang
Mai in Thailand says uh Dr bakosh
considering your specific interest in
small telescopes and their application
in your research could you elaborate on
the advantages and disadvantages of
using these in exoplanet detection as
compared to larger telescopes and Jose
Marcelino says as someone interested in
instrumentation I'm curious on your
perspective on the challenges and
opportunities of using small telescopes
for astronomical research what are some
unique advantages they offer and also in
the in the realm of extrasolar planets
what are some of the most intriguing
findings or trends that have emerged in
recent years are there any specific
characteristics or planetary systems
that have captured your attention so I
guess that's that's two questions from
the second one but okay and I want to
try to get yet another question in after
that so so that's why I see if you can
answer that quickly yeah yeah this is
this question I would need a lecture on
this basically I will try to be putting
um the trends uh very quickly first most
important there's plenty of exoplanets
essentially every Star has statistic in
exoplanet that's something that came out
from the past 20 years second the
planets in the universe are very
different from our own planets they're
ones that are very strange they are
orbiting just a few days around their
sons they're orbiting the opposite
direction as the star spin sir there are
planets that are completely unexpected
like much bigger than Jupiter in Mass
much much bigger there are planets that
we don't have in the solar system that
are between the mass of Earth and
Neptune or Neptune and Saturn all kinds
of weird things
there are many eccentric planets not
nice circular orbits like in the solar
system but they go on this widely
eccentric orbits
um and once again The Eccentric is not a
psychological State no no yeah
um just to be clear
and I'm an I think um we now know that
small planets are far more frequent than
big ones we now have a handle on the
frequency the occurrence rate of planets
and we know that long period planets are
also far more frequent than short period
ones this has been measured it's not
some rough you know we actually know the
numbers
um I think those are the most important
buzz and so the small telescope stuff
um the Charming thing is a small
telescope is obviously much much cheaper
than a big one and yet you can do a lot
of science with it and then big
telescopes can selectively follow up on
the gems that you found so it's a much
more optimal use of resources
another thing is many people are capable
of and many nations or say institutions
who are not well funded are capable of
running small telescence even students
student programs yeah exactly but to run
a Space Telescope where is the 10
billion coming from you know
agency
I think the bottom line of that question
is how many stars
of the night sky do your small
telescopes have access to because the if
the star is too dim you're not gonna you
can't do it but where's a big telescope
can monitor a dim star so how many stars
do you have enough work cut out for you
yeah so I'm just developing a new small
telescope system which will consist of
64 small telescopes in an array
each having its own detector and it will
see the whole sky above you know
reasonable elevation of about above the
Horizon and it will measure the
brightness of about 100 million stars
every 30 seconds
100 million every 30 we're good you good
you're good on that yeah yeah well then
I think that leads quite neatly into I
think that if there's time for one final
question Troy from one more let's say
Virginia says uh Dr bakosh do you
foresee the creation of a detection
method that will expand our current
model of the visible Universe wow like a
brand new one another then yeah I mean
the latest one which it was
gravitational waves right we we have
detected neutrinos right that was
amazing we do cosmic we detect cosmic
rays particles directly coming from far
away we have electromagnetic radiation
and we have gravitational waves and
um just to be clear each one of these
requires a different kind end of quote
telescope to observe right so the
gravitational waves that was ligo and
then you have neutrino detectors those
are underground Vats of the all right
and then you said electromagnetic that
would be traditional telescopes and
uh is there anything left I mean what's
left well I think what's left is for
example detecting Dark Matter okay fancy
so we don't know what dark matter is
um all we know is that it does not
interact with electromagnetic radiation
at his light okay so dark matter
detector why isn't that just detecting
its gravity isn't that well so we have
detected its gravity
um through looking at the spin of
galaxies or the properties of galaxies
it's effects but not the thing itself we
would like to see like what was it like
what's the particle but yeah the
particle is really annoying because it
does not interact with anything so and
of course the gravity of an individual
particle you can't measure you need big
lumps of this dark matter to see so
um that's sort of a new thing I think
that that's the one I would list for
this otherwise I guess
improving the detection methods for all
of these having big space telescopes
large ground-based telescopes clear
skies all together will hugely improve
our capabilities I want you to take us
out with just a a a a a commercial
for the Vera Reuben telescope and what
that will do for the measurement of
transient phenomena and then you can
wrap it in how bad the satellite Trails
would be in the face of those data
yeah so the the verruming
um survey will
um will be commissioned next year
starting
scanning the sky from Chile using a
giant telescope it has a mirror diameter
of six and a half meters and it will
scan the sky every three day three
nights every three days so top so it
will constantly work every night but
every point in the sky will get an
observation roughly every third day and
it will see very deep down very faint
thing so it will be very rich with
exploding things in the universe very
far away now having said that it's an
extremely sensitive telescope so a
satellite going through will it leads to
this giant bright streak across the
image spoiling a big part of the image
are you gonna have to only use it
outside of The Twilight Zone oh I like
the way that came out okay the evening
Twilight and morning Twilight is where
you get the reflection of the Sun so
maybe the telescope would only be at its
best between the two edges of Twilight
well these Twilights are very long so
there's a ton of that because for the
satellites what we call Twilight is
they're orbiting further up
so you can easily see them three four
hours after Sunset and three four hours
before and then you had the whole night
already so in the summer night the whole
night is Twilight but it's not the
lights in the winter nights there might
be a couple of hours in the middle that
is less fine but you're losing majority
of your time
and so if it repeats the sky every three
nights it can see it should detect
anything that varies on that kind of
time scales at a fair expectation for it
yep that is that is a fair expectation
and it will see many things that that
change either move asteroids or blow up
supernovae or Nim collapsing Stars into
a black hole or all kinds of interesting
things well you convince me let's shoot
them down let's shoot these satellites
down
in a video game as a minimum in a video
game I mean you could with with lasers
that are used for
um inter like useful Adaptive Optics I
think if one hit a satellite I'm sure
military had the technology
all right so so guys for when is your
documentary come out dark sacred night
um that documentary was um it came out
on the Garden State film festival and it
it even won a prize I forgot what price
Garden state is New Jersey for those
yeah yeah no some people think of New
Jersey as a garden and it's publicly
available on YouTube it's available out
okay yeah for a while it was only
through you know buying a ticket yeah
thank you for highlighting that for me
but now it's all open yeah so I highly
recommend it's a short documentary it's
10 minutes maybe or 15 it's okay
well gospel is in Delight it's been a
delight to have you on Star Talk and
share your expertise with us especially
from my old stomping grounds at Payton
Hall on campus at Princeton University
yeah we miss you thank you for inviting
me all right excellent and Matt always
good to have you man it's always good to
be here all right this has been Cosmic
queries Neil deGrasse Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
thank you